Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
And over the weekend I was in Los Angeles,
where I got to meet up with Henry,
the creator of MinutePhysics.
But let's get to some DONGS.
MinutePhysics recommended
Grow Cube. You win by selecting the
elements in the correct
order. I was kinda like big deal,
but then MinutePhysics pointed out
that understanding the subtle relationships
between the way the animations happen
and way the items interact is something
that the human brain is
awesome at, but computers not so much.
These's are one of the few types of games
where people can be computers. So go play
one, and after you beat it, look at the
screen and go
"take that computer."
SnipeZzLeGacY recommended Continuity,
a really clever game where you have to
rearrange the puzzle pieces
of the game to make it playable. And 'No
One Mourns the Nolan' recommended Blow
Six,
where you shoot balls at bricks to knock them
off, but using larger and larger balls
costs you points,
so be careful.
NothinbatHD sent me "Kill Me."
New versions of yourself appear
over and over again
and the bodies of your former selves can
be strategic safe zones.
DeluxeFreeman sent me the best type of koala,
the kind you have to laboriously wave
your cursor over and over and over
to divide into small enough pixels to
be intelligible.
KryptiCxLeGenD threw me a curveball
3D pong.
And oh look, a complete breakdown of
10 codes. 10-4 means OK, but there are 98 others.
Htwins.net contains some of my favorite WebWork.
These are the guys behind the amazing scale
of the universe tool I've covered before,
but they also have spatial intelligence
games like
rolling a cube, so that a certain
face faces down at the right time.
I also like this one where the guy can't
walk and you have to pre-plan
his automatic route. Joe Sabia is one of
the most creative people I know. His
internet works
are super clever. I specially like how he
made this interactive game
on Facebook.
Bob Lazar was a guy who purportedly
worked at Area 51.
What does he do now?
Well, he runs UnitedNuclear.com,
a website where you can actually buy
small,
legal quantities of radioactive
isotopes/
Finally @GothisLifeStyle @tweetsauce-d
a fantastic list of cool
mind hacks, like the Pinnochio effect or
the fact that you can not rotate one of
your feet clockwise
while simultaneously drawing the number
six in the air
without having to reverse your foot.
Pretty weird, right?
And as always,
thanks for watching.